at a private fundraiser at his
mar-a-lago Resort in Florida Donald
Trump was actually asked about his
spending and his explosion of the
national debt and according to people in
the room he said quote who the hell
cares about the budget we're going to
have a country now I've been telling you
for years this is bigger than Trump that
the debt and deficit are a political
football that's all that they are our
elected officials don't really care
about debt and deficit as long as we're
going into debt for the things they want
to spend money on and of course
historically even though Republicans are
the so-called deficit hawks Republicans
are the ones who increase the deficit
and thus more quickly increase the
national debt as well and in fact under
barack obama deficit growth slowed while
under donald trump it has absolutely
exploded and there is trump at his
mar-a-lago Resort in Florida telling
donors behind closed doors who the hell
cares about the budget we're going to
have a country the annual the Trump
annual deficit past a trillion dollars
in 2019 and Donald Trump had promised
the opposite Trump promised that he
would get us a surplus so big that the
debt itself would start shrinking and
completely disappear within eight years
now only someone who is extremely
gullible or knows nothing at all about
the debt and deficit would have even for
a second considered that that might have
actually been something that would
happen Donald Trump also promised that
his tax cuts would so acutely grow the
economy that the deficit would shrink as
a result of new economic productivity
that also has not happened some
Republicans may be believed him others
didn't but they didn't care because a
lot of them don't actually care and per
MSNBC Donald Trump has now added two
point six trillion dollars to the
national debt in just three years that's
more than Barack Obama added during his
entire second term the truth is that
even Republicans know that the deficit
in and of itself doesn't actually matter
here's a funny video of reporter Jon
Karl asking at a briefing hey you know
Trump said he'd eliminate the debt what
happened with all of that check out the
answer questions one you mentioned what
the president promised her in the
campaign during the campaign he also
promised that he would eliminate the
national debt within eight years and as
you know at the end of his first year
was a twenty trillion last year it went
to twenty one trillion last month twenty
two trillion so what happened to that
promise I mean the president has added
historically large numbers to the
national debt instead of keeping a
promise to actually pay it off look
again the last administration nearly
doubled the national debt and when this
president ran for office he made a
commitment to the American people that
he would attempt to tackle the debt
within eight years this president did
that the very first year that he came to
office by sending forth a budget that
balance within ten years
so wait Trump promised to try to do this
in eight years proposed the ridiculous
budget that would have done it in ten
and that's considered an answer to the
question and what matters are really
more detailed questions that don't get
asked questions like what are we
spending on that is growing the deficit
are we growing the deficit because we
are paying for health care or education
or is it because we're paying for
weapons as an example are we growing the
deficit or increasing our national debt
in a way that improves the well-being of
the average American or are we just like
going to war with the countries in the
Middle East what portion of our GDP is
the deficit because remember the raw
dollars of deficit in a vacuum doesn't
really tell us anything we need to
compare it to the size of the economy
what kind of deficit spending has a high
multiplier economically versus a lower
economic multiplier we've talked about
that term before I won't go into it now
but again when we go back to the
importance that Republicans themselves
place on this issue they expose
themselves time and again and reveal
that they don't actually care about the
debt and the deficit beyond it being a
tool that they can use to attack
Democrats when it's convenient this is
bigger than Trump it really is in a way
even though Trump said this behind
closed doors and probably didn't intend
for it to become public Trump is being
more honest than most of them when
he says who cares about the budget when
we have a country in the sense that that
means debt and deficit don't matter as
long as we're doing the things that I
want to do and that the people who are
going to vote for me believe that I
should be doing or want me to do any
Republican when Republicans are in power
does not care about the deficit any
Republican when there is a Democratic
president believes that the
out-of-control spending is the number
one problem and that we can somehow cut
our way to prosperity and a better
middle middle class and a better
functioning economy it's a farce and I
appreciate even if it's behind closed
doors Donald Trump just saying who cares
about it and then of course reminder any
time we talk about this we have to
continue to drill it this repeatedly we
never hear this question asked by
Republicans except for like the
occasional Rand Paul libertarian we
never hear the question but how would we
pay for this war remember when it looked
like we might be going to war with Iran
a couple of weeks ago I think Rand Paul
said something about how much it would
cost although it might have just been
about like his non interventionist stuff
that he was complaining but there's no
questions from Republicans about can we
afford war with Iran what would be the
cost where are we gonna get the money
what about the deficit what about the
debt and yet we hear all the time we
can't afford health insurance we can't
afford free public college we can't
afford to pay for matured maternity
leave or a paid sick time or whatever
the case may be it is merely a political
football used when it is convenient
don't for a second think that it is
anything other than that